it's kind of weird that at the very
moment that most of the country lives in
terror that anything you say can be
twisted into the r
word and you get fired and canceled
never heard from again we're all
exquisitely sensitive
trying to step over boundaries that
change every day
some small group of people seem to be
able to attack anyone they want on the
basis of their race
and they're celebrated for it that's
accelerating it's getting more intense
trace gallagher has the latest example
for us tonight hey trace hey tucker for
context you should know that dr
donald moss is an author and faculty
member at both the new york
psychoanalytical institute and the san
francisco center for psychoanalysis
where he tells his students that
whiteness is contagious
can be passed on by other infected
people and that you are more prone to
contract whiteness if you are
white so now dr moss has published a
report that calls whiteness a quote
malignant parasitic-like condition that
enables the host to have quote
power without limit force without
restriction violence without mercy
and a drive to quote hate and terrorize
and quote target non-white peoples but
there's good news bad news good news
parasitic whiteness is treatable he says
phew with quote
psychic and social historic
interventions including methods of
redistribution
and reparations the bad news is
whiteness has no cure
as you might imagine some are calling
this psycho nonsense quoting here
how do my colleagues consider this
scholarship anyone
actually take this seriously and this
quoting i was skeptical so i looked it
up and yeah
this is real and now i want to throw my
psychology degree in the garbage not
only is it real dr moss's report was
published in the journal of the american
psychoanalytic association
one of the most trusted publications in
psychology most trusted
essentially tucker it's it's the cnn of
psychoanalysis
an analogy we can all understand trace
gallagher great to see you tonight thank
you
does anyone take that kind of stuff
seriously yeah the answer is yeah and if
you keep talking like that
what are the consequences how's this
gonna wind up
where we going exactly it's dangerous
that's obvious
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else